and one of the things that has just
blown me away in the last year because
I've talked to lots of people lots of
people live you know but also lots of
people online but it's more obvious live
and it's obvious in this theater as well
is that I've gone around and spoken and
a large proportion of my audience has
being young men young you know under 30
something like that and I've spoken to
them a lot about responsibility and
what's so odd about about this is that
of all the things that I've spoken about
because I can see the audience and I can
feel how the audience is reacting
because I'm always paying attention to
all of you it's insofar as I can manage
that so I get some sense of how what I'm
saying is landing know what you have to
do if you're going to speak effectively
to people and what what happens is if I
talk about responsibilities everyone
being is silent just like they are now
it's silent and and not moving right
focusing attentive say pick up your
responsibilities
pick up the heaviest thing you can and
carry it and the room goes quiet and
everybody's eyes open and I think who's
makes me break up I was
I don't I don't know why I was speaking
to an English journalist today he's
going to write an article in Spectator
magazine I was talking about this and at
the same point in the discussion the
same I have the same emotional reaction
I don't really understand it but I think
it's something there's something about
it it's so crucial because you know
we've been fed this unending diet of
rights and freedoms and there's
something about that especially there's
something about that that's so
pathologically wrong and people are
starving for the antidote and the
antidote is truth and responsibility
right and it isn't it isn't because
that's what you should do and some you
know some some I know better or someone
knows better for you what you should do
sense it's that it's that it's that it's
that that's the secret to a meaningful
life and without the meaningful life
then all you have is suffering and and
nihilism and despair and all of that and
self-contempt and and that's not good
and so the man it's necessary for men to
stand up and take responsibility and
they all know that and and are starving
for that message and and the message is
more that that's also a good thing to
stand up and take responsibility because
you're cursed so much now from from from
from when you're young with this notion
that you're active engaged with with the
world is part of what is destroying and
undermining the planet and adding to the
tyranny of the social systems it's like
how about not so much of that hey
because it's it is to soul deadening
it's anti human right to the car and my
sense instead is that you know if you if
you were able to reveal the best of
yourself to you in the world that you
would be an overwhelming force for good